president Trump is the People's Choice  he's the one that we elected in 2016 we  re-elected him in 2020 and we will elect  him in 2024. what we need in this  country Brian is we need strong  Republican Governors like Ron DeSantis  we need strong Republican Governors we  need Kerry Lake to win in Arizona we  need strong Republican Governors to  fight stay in for eight years and save  their states not to abandon their states  and try to run for president or any  other big position so I wonder why she  feels that way this is for everyone  anyone that's considering running uh for  president in 2024 against President  Trump please support president Trump  because we need him back in the White  House yeah and we need him to be the  nominee so that he picks me to be his  running mate only a trump supporter  would view other candidates engaging in  the Democratic process as an act of  betrayal think about how backwards that  is